hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar HPV based cervical screening
from implementation to future
possibilities i am michelle action of
labyrinth and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by Abbott molecular to
learn more about our sponsor
please visit www.michigan.gov/mstep en't
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send Abbott will review
the questions with dr. Hawks and send
the answers to the questions via email
for the duration that the event is
available on-demand through that route
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
staff tab at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker dr. David Hawkes the director of
molecular biology and biochemistry at
the Victorian cytology Service for the
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen dr. Hawks you may now begin
your presentation
hi so today I'm going to be talking
about HPV based cervical screening from
implementation to future possibilities
my name's David hawks I'm the director
of molecular biology and biochemistry at
BCS pathology in Melbourne Australia
disclosures we do a lot of research
we've worked with most of the major
manufacturers
who donated test kids that need to be
just the ecology knowledge staff have
received any grants honorarium other
financial income gained from HPV NMFA
manufacturers we've also been lucky
enough to get a National Health Medical
Research Council grant from Australia
over five years to be a center for
research excellence in cervical cancer
control
so I guess the first thing to start off
with is there's over 300 HPD tests
available I was recently at a conference
in China where apparently there was over
200 tests available in China alone and
which ones are going to be suitable for
use in a screening program is in topic
I'm going to cover also what's an
appropriate quality framework for these
tests so we all know that test is only
as good as the stuff that run it but how
can you make sure that your staffs are
actually following all the protocols and
that the result is actually critically
better
in other areas to come up with HPV
testing that wasn't previously available
with psychology based cervical screening
programs is self collection so at the
moment it's used primarily as an
alternative for primary screening
particularly with under screen
populations but this is something that
could actually grow just in low and
middle-income countries and the final
topic I'm going to be talking about is
HPV extended genotyping and I guess this
kind comes down to whether more evidence
is in fact better for a clinical purpose
so just to give you a little bit
background of the Australian experience
we have primary HPV nucleic acid-based
testing for cervical cancer screening we
begin on the first December 2017 and we
use a HPV based primary screening with a
reflex liquid based light ology on any
positive samples as a result of that
would move from two-year cervical
cytology based screening to 5-year HPV
based screening and essentially the
document that drives what we do in the
lab is the requirements for laboratories
reporting certain screening tests now
the first edition was released in June
2017 with the program beginning on the
1st of December 2017 and 17 months later
we've already produced a second edition
which I guess is a bit of a heads up to
tell you that
things change and they change pretty
rapidly and there's a lot of things in a
national program we didn't predict that
we've had to be reactive to
we kind of went into this program
knowing that this was going to be the
case we wouldn't be able to have a fully
form perfect document outre outlining
what we were going to be doing from day
one we're always going to have to be a
bit like so we've already got the second
edition of this document I sit on both
this committee and also the original
committee and at the moment we're
looking to sort of finalize that second
edition and will we actually go straight
into working on the third dish
but this is just a general idea of the
cervical screening pathway in Australia
so what I'll be dealing with most is in
this blue box which is essentially this
for possible outcomes for HPV test
there's a basically they're not
protected there's a high screen on 16 9
18 detected and there's a HPV 16 18
detected and then finally there's an
unsatisfactory HPV test I'm sure those
of you who've been in the HPV of the
cervical screening world over the last
decade will have seen this figure and
this gives the cumulative incidence of
CIN 3 so cervical intraepithelial
neoplasia grade 3 or above over 10 years
the top line being the HPV 16 positive
the next one being the 18 positives so
these two in the Australian program if a
patient has a positive reason 16 or 18
they're considered at high-risk then we
also have in the the yellow the non 1618
high-risk HPV positives so there's still
an elevated risk over HDTV negative but
you can clearly see there's quite a
large difference between the predicted
value of a 1618 and another that other
in this study was another 11 HPV types
in the Australian program most other
programs that sort of moved to 12 HPV
types with the addition of a 366 and
sickly 8 on top of the WH o credited 12
allergenic types so this is just a bit
of a background into what we decided in
Australia was going to be the
requirements for HPV sa there's a number
of other aspects that is particular to
Australia that has to be registered
where that reputed Goods Administration
and this will change from country to
country but what I'm going to focus on
is essentially the quality framework for
choosing a NSA so it must satisfy an
adapted my criteria which is essentially
a test of sensitivity specificity and
reproducibility against a reference si
now the reference si is
the hybrid catch - or the GP 5 + 6 +
we've now had the one of the essays
approved with the 4800 is a reference
essay and currently the my criteria is
being revisited by an international
consortium so that's why we're calling
in an adaptive my criteria rather than
industry by criteria it must be
validated for primary population-based
screening yes a must contain a control
monitor for inhibition and/or si value
now this was a very controversial issue
in Australia prior to the introduction
of these requirements and then it's
become a non-issue so for some essays
they they test for a cellular protein so
beta globin is probably the most common
and that's used to measure inhibition
traditionally by the assays villages
also by default and measure of
cellularity which is the next point so
this vehicle over can be used for both
inhibition and cellular some essays have
different controls for both but one
single cellularity that shows
amplification and cellularity cellular
genes is is more than adequate and
finally there's the self question
specimens must be tested using a DNA PCR
based test
the evidence for this was based on the
2014 meta-analysis by mark Arvin and
since then the 2018 review of this is
actually just strengthened that there's
no difference in sensitivity between our
PCR based self collected and a PCR based
clinician collected assay so according
to the the Australian program these are
the seven essays that are currently able
to be used in the program now because
it's a quality framework rather than
selecting which assays listing them this
can change and this will certainly
evolve over time there's another number
of assays that I suspect will be added
to this list in the next probably six to
nine months so the co-best 4,800 the
Abbott real-time theologic Optima the
video piracy gene are thus afid and the
rocha totus 6800 now when you look
through these essays and this is a table
I always include because that's what I
probably get asked the most is we want
just a single table that tells us what
we can and can't do so this meets the
the impact criteria screening
cellularity you know you notice it's an
asterisk next to the logic a permit
that's because they have an IV D based
cellular control looking at a mRNA
expression of a human cell and that's
not validated by the manufacturing so it
depends on what the local requirements
are on to how adaptive that that can be
used but it's also done it's a separate
sample which means that the whole logic
Optima on the Panther has a reduced
throughput down to 130 in an eight-hour
day it's also not a PCR based assay so
that can't be used for self collection
all the others pretty much tick every
box and as you can see there's a
variation in in the eight-hour work flow
from this sort of the 288 of the the
kovash 4,800 and the Abbott real-time
through to sort of the Lister feed
expert in the code at 6,800 now the so
feed expert is a modular system so you
can have a single modular system which
can do
ah seven in eight hours or you could
have the infinity 80 which has 80
modules which can theoretically do 560
and eight hours essays like the Rocha
Kobus 1600 can actually put on quite a
lot of samples overnight so just beware
the the throughput in eight hours is not
necessarily that representative of the
capacity of these machines in in a real
lab experience but it is sort of the
eight hour is used as the metric for
showing that the volumes these assays
can actually turn through so the other
question I often get up to international
conferences what are people using so to
live the private pathology networks in
Australia using a combination to Roche
forty eight hundred and sixty-eight
hundred systems that's because in
Australia we have long distances between
all of our our capital cities where most
of the work is done and different
different labs have different needs so
we have Sydney which is City over five
million whereas we have sort of smaller
cities of only couple hundred thousand
where a six year and would be necessary
third private pathology system uses the
avidin mm system the majority public
laboratories use a combination those
forty eight hundred sixty eight hundred
we've got one laboratory using the whole
logic Optima with the IBD cellularity
control and two laboratories using the
seeds from any place to system
so just to give you an idea of what
Theseus does because we are said that
Sugo screening reference will originally
we're not a government laboratory but
we're also not a private laboratory we
are using both a sixty eight hundred and
forty eight hundred we've got an M&M mm
beating on clarity in a CG in any Plex
to these five instruments I use for our
normal screening work we also have an
abbot expert we have a point-of-care but
we also have a infinity eighty we don't
tend to use them because in a
high-volume laboratory that is the cost
Podesta's dearer and it's not sort of a
financially viable option but as a point
of care device it certainly got some
very big advantages we've got an a
battle in EDM coming in in the next
month and then when the SI is for
interested in quarter three 2019 we'll
be using that primary screening once
we've got all the Maya criteria the
other other quality framework items
ticked off there's a small Australian
device called the Oz Diagnostics and
we've also got the sort of the
foundational HPV typing essays over a
linear rate that's been discontinued
next year so as a result of having all
these tests and and all these different
targets we were able to actually look
into what these what these results mean
into a wider context of screen now we've
already published one paper about first
116,000 screening tests stratified by
age our screening program runs from 25
to 74 you can have a look at the top two
tables at HPV 16 and 18 and the bottom
table on the left is any HPV and on the
right mr. nan 1618 HPV so what you can
see here is that there is
it's definitely a
[Music]
factor of age so young women who have
started having different sexual partners
and then family at severals down over
time so bye-bye 40 there's sort of a
Venus steep decline from 25 to 40 of the
rate of infections but what we can see
is with Australia having such a high
vaccination rate over 80% but for women
there is no we don't see this peak in
HPV 16 and 18 we expect as time goes on
this sort of the 618 and the old women
will actually start up all right as the
vaccinated cohort ages the other thing
we really want to make clear is the
different assays give different results
so
this is a paper published six years ago
by Jack guzik in British Journal of
cancer it shows that we've got the BD
we've got the Roche we've got the hybrid
capture the abbot and the app them are
all in there you look at the discordant
results between the different tests and
you look at the still looking about
point eight on average between all these
different assays now if I was to see
this on a chlamydia test I'd probably be
quite worried because chlamydia has an
analyte control essentially we're going
to detect any true positive in a
chlamydia test however HPV is a risk
stratification test rather than a
diagnostic test we don't want to detect
every single positive in every single
case because although a positive test
does lead to investigation not
necessarily treatment you're more likely
to over treat in particularly younger
women because obviously that's where the
high rate of infections are and it means
biopsies or leads or letters on those
women will most likely have an effect on
their ability to carry a child to term
and other sort of issues so we only want
to detect the HPV these that are
associated with disease and probably the
most elegant way of showing this was a
number of studies gesture bond and
revolver you would show that when you
look at the concordance of these four
essays which is a hybrid capture Clark
Cove s and n Optima you've got a hundred
samples which have a less than ten one
which is you know what we'd probably be
looking at this normal cytology only 34%
were positive for four essays however
once you go to seat or above is
logically confirmed suddenly you're
looking at eighty four percent and
that's what we're looking at and with
this eighty four percent
none of the positives are positive on
just one just one test so so emotional a
positive on three so
just shows that
the tests really come together when
you're looking at HPV results associated
with disease but yet there were
absolutely will be some wobble when
you're looking at sort of just infection
that's not associated with disease and
we get a lot of questions about
highlighting the skin - we get a lot of
questions where a woman will have any
HPV 6 infection she'll go for ' it could
be a month or two later they take a
sample and she's just needed at that age
could be and what we often do is we can
go back and look at the the value and
often that initial HPV 16 is is close to
the cutoff within a couple of cycles of
the cutoff of being defined as positive
that's how it works that is just the
nature of these types of essays and it's
not something that should be worried
about I mean it just needs education
particularly for the practitioners that
are using it and we've found that over
the last of 18 months more and more
practitioners are getting more and more
comfortable with these sorts of results
now
you've got a test you're very happy with
the test now you sort of got to work on
how you make sure that that test pays in
the way that it should so we know that
sources of variability need controls to
monitor the quality so I'm just sort of
run down a few of the general areas that
we need to look at and running on
running a microbiology lab this will be
exactly as you have been doing for years
and years and years so we know that
different instruments give different
results so we have a couple of 4800 s we
know that they're slightly different so
the external QC controls need to be run
on each machines they use you can't just
if you had say five a bit in two
thousand can't run the quality samples
on just one and then test the other ones
because you will get variations we know
that different reagents or different QC
controls themselves can give different
results so we had a batch of the acute
control where the manufacturer had put
in the same amount of cells but because
the number of HIV copies varies per cell
we actually got a couple of I think
we've got three or four cycles different
in how to see when we change batches and
so we were able to track that down and
solve the issue would resolve it but it
just shows that the dukey's controls
themselves can actually be a source of
variation also know that different
reagents can behave slightly differently
so what we do is we we keep a record of
all reagents producing a results so that
if we have an issue with any reagents we
can tell which results were actually
produce then if we need to go back and
look at whether the positivity has
changed we can actually track all that
Dancer basic management
primo biology 101 is that all reagents
and processes possible sources of
contamination so on top of running
positive and negative controls we also
run empty controls for for us that's a
generally a thin profile and so we run
those through our pre analytics and our
essays and everything else like that or
we run the same control for an entire
week and that minus or any both HPV
contamination but also if there's any
sort of cells because these are
amplification zones in each application
essays these human cells it's always
been a source of concern that you'll get
to skin cells or any other sort of cells
giving false positives for the presence
of beta globin now we've been running
those controls for 18 months and we've
never actually found cellular
contamination but we will continue to
run them through the entire process
pretty much every day so the other thing
to do is tomorrow to HPV positivity to
detect changes sometimes you get
variation so if you get a particularly
younger cohort of women in or you get a
particular older cohort you clearly will
see differences in HPV now different
labs also have different population
bases they serve and a variety of the
parameter so it's difficult to compare
across labs certainly within your lab
you should have a bit of an idea of what
your your general positivity will be and
also the general breakdown of community
so in Australia we consider anyone born
from the 1st through July 1980 or
afterwards part of what we call the
vaccinated cohort so they were people
that were offered the HPV vaccine free
as part of the Australian national
program and people born before May Day
we consider the unvaccinated cohort it
doesn't mean that that people couldn't
have paid and got the vaccine but just
generally as a population base and at
the moment that ties in very nicely with
see those women at 37 38 which is about
the point at which the HPV positivity is
going down but it's a date that we
actually have to keep flexible because
obviously the vaccination of the women
in that area only affects 16 and 18 and
as we can see premiered the previous
data that's not where we're going to get
most of our variation in volatility
based on age
as I said earlier one of the things that
changes with a HPD base cervical
screening program is the ability to
actually use self collection to cytology
you need to click from particular areas
from the cervix you need to get a
certain number of cells and there's a
lot of skill involved in this and in you
need practitioner to actually undertake
it a with subcollection it's much
simpler now in Australia we have a
number of regulations to make sure that
self collection is only offered to
subset of population so there must be
over 30 must be more than two years
overdue for screening which at the
moment means they're four years in their
lives at cytology but within another
year that will be sort of start to be
seven years since their last HPV test
they must have refused practitioner
collected which is you know a shorthand
for saying a specular examination and it
must be collected within a clinical
setting so this isn't in Australia in
other programs there are male out of
question kits in Australia it's all done
in a clinical setting so a practitioner
will offer a woman a just a question
just say no they might offer them self
collection she'll get the device and be
able to take our own sample so in terms
of Australia since 2018 under a never
screen women two thousand have been out
to access self question the majority of
those three bases that Olivia's we were
the first credible poetry and the own
little oratory until relatively recently
in early 2019 and that's because we
needed an IV D validation because there
were no PCR assays that have
manufacturer validated sub-question
claims now there is a variety of
different question devices available on
the market
some of them are very good from a
quality point of view some of them
there's not a huge amount of evidence we
went with a copan flock swab for a
couple of reasons firstly it's a
relatively cheap device at under $1 in
Australia this ubiquitous so this is
found in nearly every GP clinic in some
way or another because it is used for so
you can use it for nasopharyngeal
there's a whole variety of reasons and
it's useful so you don't need a
particular self collection specific
device and it so the patient takes the
dry swabs and they put it back in the
sleeve and then it comes through to the
pathology lab
now in terms of under screening as a
respective cervical cancer this is data
from Victoria and it's it's a report
from 2015 so that's the most recent data
we have and it just sort of goes on to
show that this is the group that is all
under screened and if you can sort of
see by the further High Line sirs of the
invasive cancer sort of the never
screened and the lamp screeners make up
70% of those and it's almost exactly
when you include invasive and micro
invasive again at 70 percent those that
are sort of laps by less than two and a
half years there's only one case so it
doesn't make that much of a difference
but yet 70 percent of women with cancer
in Victoria are under on in the screen
the biggest respective getting several
cancerous is not being screened
that's why self lecture is going to be a
bit of a game-changer in Australia
so in order to do a clinical validation
cell collection we needed to know what
was going to be a good assays
so we now know from the the updated
Arvind meta-analysis in 2018 that PCR
based assays are not less sensitive than
collection collected so it's 95%
confidence interval of elijah's through
different devices you know 0.87 to 1.04
it doesn't really matter with use of
brushes swab or lavage you're going to
end up with a no less sensitive essay
there's marginally less specific and
that varies depending on the collection
device
when we're looking at a population that
doesn't screen I think there's less
concerned with the specificity
particularly when it's sort of very
close to its point nine eight but for a
couple of devices then it is with having
something that's going to be less
sensitive so if you have a thing that
you know using an essay like the hybrid
capture we're actually looking at they
were systole less sensitive said they're
only about point eight four and that was
again statistically significant so the
PCR based assays are the way to go so
the other thing to consider is this sort
of designer collection so mail-outs
collection at home has a participate of
about twenty percent it's a
meta-analysis so that we actually
undertook with our under screen
population offering an init clinic we
had a participation rate of over eighty
five percent again this is not a
systematic review or a meta-analysis is
just what we found but yet we've also
got anecdotal information from our
actual national program that there is a
very high uptake which is why
Australia's sticking with the clinical
offering rather than attend a mail app
that's being used in other jurisdictions
at the moment so as I mentioned earlier
we had to get an HIV D
to use the the self collection in
Australia so the way that we did this
was we undertook a sub collection study
which we called the scope and we did 303
samples so this was to determine
statistical non-inferiority we had a
previous study that had 42% positive so
that was what we based it on we ended up
getting both 50% positives in a
colposcopy clinic again an enriched
sample so we're actually we met that
power quite easily we use self question
versus a flock swab stored for seven
days at room temperature prior to things
very suspended five mils of preserving
site which is temperate by being swell
for 20 seconds we want to keep this
simple and easy so we've done further
stability where we've actually had that
block swab with a very low level of HPV
at 50 degrees Celsius and under percent
humidity for two weeks taking samples
out regularly and looking at the
positivity and they're perfectly fine
but also testing it at minus twenty
degrees again perfectly fine
so we sort of did seven days originally
but we've actually done further
stability studies on those we then
compare them with practitioner collected
in prep using the collection device all
the practitioners choice than just only
a broom or a brush this is obviously
given ethical approval and this is sort
of the data that we have on the abbot in
2000 so what you see is you've got some
very good concordance so it's something
too negative it's generally negative on
both it's positive it's positive on both
and then we have a few samples that are
self collection positive or practition
collected negative or self question
negative practition collector positive
and what you can see is that there is
definitely a trend that the self
collection is more sensitive I'll
explain why in a minute but again your
sixteen rating there's only tips you
know you're still getting 26 positives
for both of those and it's you know HPV
18 it's very similar so there's not a
huge degree of variation
and then when we look at all of those
sort of self question practitioner
collected as sort of a grouping rather
than sort of just positive and negatives
this you know same amount of 16 1 of 18
and very similar amount of other HTTP
again the self collection is more
sensitive and the reason for this is
that the self collection was always
taken first this is a capacity clinic
women who are going in for ' had a
biopsy or another treatment and it was
not considered either ethical or
feasible to get them to take a self
collection upwards we know from other
studies such as this study by panel
woman where they did the same device and
Jona specimens on the left and the
cervical specimens on the other axis we
can see that in the red this the journal
positive difficult egative we're always
much higher than the other way around so
ended up being 54 with vagina positive
typical negative and only 12 where the
other way around and that's because the
first sample collected seems to be more
sensitive and whether it's a cervical or
a vaginal you seem to click the HP
videos in the vaginal canal and that's
that's one of the drawbacks of our study
but it's also a well-known bias and
realistically we couldn't do too much
about that
so the last topic I'm going to get to is
that genotyping and the question about
whether it's the future of screening
we know that longitudinal data is
focused on either high-risk HPV positive
V or stratification of 1618 and the the
other groups as I mentioned before so
this is again one of those classic
tables like dil nur 2008 which shows the
cumulative incidence of sin 3 comparing
HPV negative inbred cytology negative in
blue and a psycho negative HPV negative
in green and this six years data for
this the the early studies showed ten
years data
just bring up again for ease of use the
amount of data we have on further
phenotyping is still unclear as if
there's some small studies but we
certainly don't have the decade-long
longitudinal data that we have but what
we do have is increasing commercial
moderate to high volume automated assays
with extended and basted I mean beyond
16 and 18 genotyping so the BD on
priority breaks down the 14 HPV types to
9 groups the C gene gives you all 14
individually that the expert takes your
14 times and breaks them into five
groups and your L in any M takes your
your 14 types and breaks them into it
slightly different part groups so what
we know is that these essays are going
to develop over time and we all start to
get more and more information we know
that some of the full genotyping assays
have done hundred thousand tests in some
jurisdictions but at the moment that's
just sort of a snapshot of infection and
as I said shown earlier we know that HPV
is a risk stratification as I'm not a
diagnostic on so it's not quite as
simple as just sort of showing
accordance of infection with other
infections we what we want to see is
their predictive value going into the
future and as we can't we don't really
have lots of data on that at the moment
we've got to kind of look at it
alternatively so what I'm going to talk
about is what is the evidence for the
value of extended HD there genotyping
they're forming quick clinical decision
making because I think that you can look
at the research and have all sorts of
arguments about different types and but
at the end of the day
these heifers the pathology lab what
we're interested in is giving
evidence-based clinical advice to our
practitioners for them to assist in
their decision-making so I'm going to
talk about Australian data just because
there is a wealth of data but this just
sort of keeps that avails can find as we
can and we've also got a very strong
screening program so as sort of it sort
of shows what happens you know even in a
good screening program so there was a
study called the acts study which was
done led by Julia Brotherton from BCS
and they they took over 800 cancers over
ten years finishing 2015 so it's
relatively recent data and they found
that 92.9% where HPV positive now
that means basically was a detective in
7% again these are histological
specimens and there were slides now
formalin-fixed so there is probably a
degree of lack of sensitivity that means
that not all of these not detectives
would necessarily be negative however
what we did find was that nearly 91%
were positive for the 14 HPV types that
we test so these are these are cancers
not screening samples but actual cancers
so between 93 percent that were HPV
positive and ER 90.6% that were positive
to the sites we test with it was only
2.3 percent difference now a lot of
people who are critical at HPV based
screening salable mostly Essos don't
test for all the HPV types and that is
absolutely true again this is a screen
test on a diagnostic testing we're
detecting 90% of
the types that cause cancers and missing
to an R percent now where we'll be in in
15-20 years when we've had the full
effect of things like the Gardasil 9
vaccine this will have to be reduce it
but at the moment I think it's a fairly
good predictor now
as you can see the quadrivalent HPV in
the celeriac types are covered by 1618
which accounts for 70% of cancers then
you've got the additional types in green
covered by the quadrivalent and as you
can see that covers overwhelmingly the
cancers in the Australian context as
shown by this individual study then what
I've done here is I've just broken it
down slightly differently to what we're
getting from our our general genotyping
so most in Australia they're 16 and 18
go through one clinical pathway the
other HPV types go through a separate
pathway
however this is us about 5,000 samples
we've run with full genotyping and as
you can see that there's quite a
difference between the prevalence of the
HPV types that don't cause cancer in the
month of Dhu cause cancer so what you're
looking at here is type 52 and n type 58
are probably the most prevalent in this
population very little HPV 18 few are
the different types
this sort of shows that the infection
doesn't really meet up with the cancer
too well and could actually add up the
figures from the graph a couple of
slides ago and shows obviously we've got
quite a lot of HPV 16 and that causes
52% of cancer HPV 18 just under 20
percent of cancer 31.1%
4.3 percent when you look at fifty two
point two percent of cancers were
positive and in our study 0.6 percent
positive to 58
even though we had nearly 8% positive
for HPV 66 there was not being shown to
be associated with any other cancers in
our act study and very few associated
with HPV 68 so
to just show this data again so this is
just the right show of cancer to
infection ratio so there's
four times as much cancer so though with
HPV 16 than you'd expect from the actual
air vector made so that just over 10
percent infection but over 50 percent of
cancers HPV 18 even stronger with you
just under 3 percent of infections being
with HPV 18 but 20 percent associated 20
percent of cancers and you have a look
there's actually only one other HPV type
that is enriched in cancer compared to
the general population at HPV 45 which
has always been acknowledged is probably
the most likely to be sort of the next
on the list after 16 and 18 due to sort
of a is and a few of the different
clinical reasons now a number of the HPV
SSO like this afid and the aftermath can
give a combined 1845 6 in 1845 result
for partial genotyping and that's that's
probably quite well-founded but
at the moment that doesn't seem to be a
lot of reason to sort of base clinical
judgments on individual genotyping
however what it's a small study about
sweet screen that actually shows if
somebody is persistent with a single
type within seven years all of these
cases ended up with cin two plus so as a
screening test i don't think there is
enough evidence to suggest that we we
need to actually base clinical pathways
on those results but i think that
certainly knowing if someone who's got
sort of a persistent infection is
persistent at the same time there's
definitely sort of emerging the other
showing that that has though you
obviously if you're looking at a someone
who's younger and having different
sexual partners the chances are they've
got an on 16 on 18 they might have
different types and that might help them
avoid going for investigate continue the
investigations or if you have someone
who's in their 50s or 60s with as had a
long stable partner they coming up with
nan 16 on 18 this might actually help
that as well
so I think that just in summing up
finance my own question of whether
genotyping is the future of screening
currently it is not depth of evidence to
support risk stratification based on
individual genotyping that's at a
screening level there is increase
amounts of data from national screening
programs so Australia Portugal and
others that the predictive value
individual phenotyping will become
clearer over time so at the moment we're
sort of when you're doing research
studies where you have 40 50 60 70
thousand people you've kind of they're
expensive and take a long time whereas
with national programs in Australia
we've screen nearly probably over two
million women and we have a registry
that monitors all of those set outcomes
so we'll the FCA are able to mine that
data from programs portugal's moving
towards HPV based screening program and
as I said they've done a lot of full
genotyping as part of one of their labs
is is working on that si the other thing
is the effect of the national
vaccination programs on the prevalence
of 1618 likely play a role in the
emerging value of extended genotyping if
you're only looking at 16 and 18 at 16
and 18 have actually dropped to
negligible levels then obviously the
value of the other HPV types
particularly the big artists online
included types which we showed earlier
associated with overwhelmingly the non
69 18 cancers so that's 31 33 45 52 and
58 these will likely be sort of the next
the next group that will be
extended genius typing playing a
clinical role so I'll just finish with
my acknowledgments to thank the the
other staff at BCS foundation Liberal
Women's Hospital dysplasia clinic in
Melbourne who allow the students of
collection study can't cancel New South
Wales who we've collaborated with on our
number of our studies and all the staff
at the BCS pathology laboratory who
actually do the work
thank you
dr. Haas for your informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar if you have a
question like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask the question box
located on the far left of your screen
our first question is based upon your
experience what has been the biggest
challenges that your laboratory has
based upon the implementation of HP TV
based primary screening programs
I think that there was a number of
challenges in our program because it was
very new and we were using a number of
different assays so learning how the
quality control work being out the
source that has become easier but also
those little things that we never
expected so we're in a busy day we might
do 1600 tests which means we have to get
rid of 1600 miles a month later in every
vowel you have to uncap it and pour out
the the flammable liquids in so actually
getting the amount of waste we were
processing became much much larger than
we probably expected Emily it actually
went very smoothly we use a variety of
different devices how staff well-trained
they had competencies yeah we just sort
of kicking records for all the different
things that are happening in different
pathways in the program we're probably
what we we didn't expect you'd be
surprised at what doctors will end up
ordering yes from a lab point of view
there wasn't actually too much that was
problematic
great thank you what are some of the
lessons learned that you can share with
the audience given that there are so
countries who are in the process or
about to implement HPV based cervical
cancer primary screening programs
things I think the one thing that we
would absolutely recommend is
communication is key so the Australian
program will probably not as good at
communicating with our practitioners as
we could have been and definitely we've
we've seen the level of education and
the acceptance of the different program
from our practitioners increase
exponentially as we educated them so I
would sort of say state your education
of your practitioners early tell them
what the test result will mean even you
know understanding what an
unsatisfactory result means so that you
know the practitioner will go we'll what
did I do wrong
and whether it was too much lubricant or
knowing ourselves all of these things
are really what the practitioner wants
to know so education early and often
thank you you had mentioned self
collection devices which must be
collected within a clinical setting what
type of education was required for the
collection to be done correctly and how
involved with a laboratory in these
efforts
illustrated the light reacts the drive
self collection it's sort of it is
available on the program but HD
laboratory has their own different way
of doing it we actually utilized a sub
collection a for one sided how to
amplitude everyone found it really
really easy and it wasn't hard and just
showed a woman how to collect your own
sample what you know she needs to rotate
it three times we had practitioners
going out and talking to groups of
doctors telling them this is when it's
appropriate and this when it isn't but a
lot of those were specific to Australia
in the conditions based around self
collection but yeah it's been extremely
easy and it wasn't wasn't it all harder
I mean a lot of women for a whole
variety of reasons have already self
collected for for group three
Cryptococcus for you know in pregnancy
or chlamydia or gonorrhea those sorts of
things so it was actually probably the
easiest part of the whole program
right thank you your next question is do
you know what percentage of the
population perform self collection for
cervical screening and do you expect
this number to increase
so in Australia that had about 2,000
women out of about two million women who
screen do subcollection it's quite
restrictive and there hasn't been hasn't
been widely available
we know that in Australia were in
Victoria about 87% of women have
screened within five years so that means
at least thirteen percent of women in
Victoria a state of just under five
million eligible for screening so we
expect those numbers to go up but when
you look at programs like Malaysia
Malaysia is introducing a national HPV
based screening program and it's going
to be based on self collection so it
will be all self collection so several
million women doing self collection I
think that it sort of how many women are
involved will depend on the individual
country and how accessible is we
certainly know that women much prefer
self collection we have we are
restricted in to who we can test so if a
woman self clicks we're not actually
allowed to test it according to our
credit ation unless she meets the
criteria otherwise I think we would have
been doing at least ten times as much
self correction
thank you when the laboratory receives
these self collection devices to test
for HPV are there any additional steps
that the lab needs to do prior to
running the test
so I think the thing is it's very
similar to getting any swab so we get
our swabs in we put them in five mils of
preserves site we swirl it for 20
seconds we take the swab out then we can
put that sample in the machine to go so
it's actually very straightforward
there's no pretreatment there's no any
any other different things we have to
all right your next question is what is
your opinion on reporting out all the
high risk HPV genotypes and do you
believe there's value in doing film
I guess you know I've spoken about this
and as I also showed we've got a number
of assays that we use routinely the
screens that have different levels of
genotyping in Australia the clinical
outcomes are based on a 16 positive an
18 positive or another positive and
that's what we report how we do have
full genotyping essays and if we get a
special request from a doctor that once
the individual genotyping will put it as
a note on the bottom of the report but
otherwise we just give the HPV result as
it as it goes in with the clinical
guidelines we have a national cervical
screening register we actually give them
all in our results so every individual
time can be traced back retroactively ly
as they need to but at the moment that's
what we do other labs actually give
every type that we find that that just
leads to more confusion
what is your opinion on the future of
HPV beyond cervical cancer screening
I think that there's a growing body of
work with HPV associated with with anal
cancers and certainly Auto pharyngeal
cancers are becoming more and more
interesting there's certainly HPV
associated penile cancers that it is
generally at a fairly low rate I think
that as we get a really strong base and
high volumes of HPV testing cervical
screening because the test will go down
and/or allow these other other cancers
which are not quite as strongly linked
to HPV so cancer to be able to piggyback
on those technologies and yeah I think
screening for low pharyngeal cancer will
be something that will occur maybe
instead of selective populations
initially but overall it will probably
be something that will become more
common in that thanks sort of five to
ten years
thank you what is your opinion about
Home Collection for HPV testing and what
challenges or opportunities do you
believe this will bring to the
laboratory and for primary screening
testing
so I think I'm flexing PageSpeed they're
testing this great there's a lot of
studies as I spoke about that have used
it it's very well accepted but the
response rates are low so it's about 20%
we've done a study here at BCS where we
sent out several thousands of
essentially a type of Bach swab we've
got 1600 back in now that was great but
it's not quite as good as in a clinic
but
from a bad point of view it's the same
device it makes no difference whether we
get it in from a clinic or whether we
get it in from home are the only thing
that would have to be aware of is that
if someone collected at home and they
don't send it in immediately there's
just sort of an increased risk of their
sort of being beyond the the claims of
validation so it doesn't get sent in for
three or four weeks we'd probably have
difficulty testing it because we don't
know of the the stability of that sample
thank you all right your next question
is how big of an issue are lubricants
from testing HPV since there are various
different types of lubricants out in the
market and are there certain lubricants
that introduce more issues than others
um I guess we've been quite lucky just
before we move to HPD Bay screening we
we had a short period in Australia where
we move to liquid-based cytology and I
know another a number of other countries
use liquid-based cytology routinely
generally we don't have a problem with
lubricants because if you have a problem
with lubricants they'll impact the good
base psychology sample for they'll
actually pet the HPV just because the
elbe sees the filters and the other
methods of actually processing the slide
are more sensitive to it we haven't had
any particular lubricants that have been
problematic what we had done is we did a
bit of study of unsatisfactory results a
couple of years ago what we actually
found was overwhelmingly I think it was
38 in Bella result down to 22,000 only
one or two of them had sufficient cells
and we're inhibited due to the lubricant
all the others were had insufficient
cells and so that's that's what we see
is much more of an issue than than
lubricant per se I know in a number of
countries they don't actually even use
lubricant so I think that our our
practitioners recommend a 5 cent piece
on the end of the speculum at most but
yeah it's sort of in terms of the
different lubricants it's not been an
issue to a point where we've actually
had to look into it I know that for
their liquid base totalities biggest
lubricants with carbon is in it but it's
not something we sort of see as much of
an issue with the HPV assays
thank you dr. Hawkes do you have any
final comments for our audience
I think that HPV is an amazing way to
actually level the playing field for
women that can actually be involved in
cervical screen that was never possible
with a psychology based program and yet
it's sort of learn from people who have
introduced in other countries there's a
lot of things you'll never be sure of
there's a lot of good essays but make
sure that you have an essay that has a
quality framework around it thank you
thank you again dr. Hawk for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor Abbott molecular for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions questions
we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration Matt routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time suffice